writing the batman title it's a dream  come true batman's cool  i really want to hit the ground running  and kind of go big right out of the gate  things explode the punches are thrown  and batman's in the fight of his life  bruce wayne is having kind of nightmares  of the future and his past is catching  up to him so both of those things kind  of involve this new villain named  failsafe  is  as a batman reader myself i love picking  up an issue and kind of feeling the  excitement on the page the cool visuals  the big status quo changing moments it's  just kind of relentless like it's kind  of a chase across the dc universe there  are a lot of kind of twists and turns  and surprises i'll say i'm a tim drake  fan so that was fun getting to have him  team up with uh bruce in our opening  arcade  it's all iconic being able to um  to write those scenes with those items  and those characters has been  surreal  [Music]  you